when you look at canada
at the moment
what are our problems
well the the central underlying illness
is a monstrous growth in the power and
cost of the state
at the expense of the agency and freedom
of the people i'm here simply restoring
what can it already belong to canadians
um by virtue of their 800-year
inheritance of
english liberties going back to the
magna carta
i'm just among the common people who are
custodians of that freedom while we're
alive you know edmund burke said it's a
contract between the dead the living and
the yet to be born
and we're the living generation has the
duty
to pass on that inheritance
and that's what i i see myself doing is
to
re-kindle that inheritance and pass it
on to
my kids and so they can pass it on to
their kids and
i'll pass away into the
fade away into the the past one day but
hopefully we'll have secured the freedom
that we inherited for many more
generations to come and that's that's
what i mean when i want to give people
back control over life in the present
it's also
um to extend it into the future
so that's my purpose that's why i'm
running i you know people want to
support me my by
pierre4pm.ca
um yes that's pr4 the number four
pm.ca is how you can sign up become a
member and do that and i would be
honored to have people's support in this
enterprise
[Music]
hello everyone i'm very pleased today to
have with me mr pierre pauliev he is the
current front-runner in the race
for leadership of the federal
conservative party of canada and he is
therefore a likely candidate
for prime minister of canada within the
foreseeable future within the next few
years the conservatives in canada have
served historically alternatively to
lead canada competing with the liberals
primarily at the federal or national
and provincial or state level
although the liberals their primary
opponents have been more historically
successful they've served more terms
have served as a senior cabinet minister
in prime minister stephen harper's
conservative government
prior to the recent election of justin
trudeau and the liberals and has served
as a member of parliament
for seven terms and with that brief
introduction i'm going to turn
the discussion over to mr pauliev who
can fill us in on little biographical
information so we know who he is and
then we'll turn to more specific issues
thanks very much for agreeing to talk to
me today and welcome
thanks very much uh dr peterson great to
be with you
so we'll do jordan and pierre how was
that that's fine by me all right away we
go so let's let's start who are you who
are you where'd you come from and how
did you get interested in politics and
why are you the man for the job here
thank you well like you i'm from alberta
although further south i come from
calgary
and
my folks are from saskatchewan uh they
married in 77 moved to calgary
where they adopted me i was born of a 16
year old unwed mother
whose mother had just died and so she
was in no position to raise a child
so she put me on for adoption and i was
blessed to be
adopted by
marlene and dawn paulia two teachers
from saskatchewan and
a pretty normal upbringing i grew up in
the 80s and
like i was born in 79 so my early
childhood was in the 80s uh it was kind
of a brutal time to be
a homeowner or a family because there
was these monstrous interest rates so
some of my early earliest memories as a
child were
the
financial stress that my folks were
going through
uh and a lot of people were losing their
homes and
their livelihoods at that time
and uh i think that made an early
impression on my
thinking even though at the time i
didn't really understand what was
happening or why i was able later on to
look back at that
strain and stress and then try to
diagnose it
when i i was old enough to understand
and um and that kind of formulated some
of my political ideologies
we can return to that later on but i you
know i grew up uh
middle class
a couple of uh teachers who got divorced
when i was in my mid to teens and uh
sort of bounce back and forth between
mom and dad's place throughout my
teenage years
went to university of calgary
yeah so we do have a fair bit in common
because my one of my parents my father
is a teacher they're both my parents are
from saskatchewan they moved to alberta
same lots of people from saskatchewan
did i got interested in politics at an
early age i remember that period of
inflation because well well i might my
parent my father and maybe your parents
did they lose their pensions when the
banks collapsed they teach because the
teachers did
mine didn't lose their pensions we did
have to move um because i i think in
retrospect that was because of the
interest rate hikes we i'm guessing my
folks were not able to pay the mortgage
at the higher rates um and then we had
to move to a smaller place and
uh we to sell our car and get us to get
a
down downgrade our automobile and all of
the above just to kind of keep our heads
above water and that would have been i'm
guessing around sort of 83-84
and that was a really kind of hellish
time particularly in alberta because the
central government had
unleashed a wicked assault on the energy
sector called the national energy
program
uh and simultaneously the worst of the
trudeau socialist years were
coming to bear on the entire national
economy so you had 12 percent inflation
12 percent unemployment
24 mortgage rates that's real fun for
everyone yes and um highest misery index
in canadian history that's unemployment
plus inflation that was under justin's
father yes surprise surprise yes and
here we are with the same policies
leading to the same
results just as the
dog returns to its vomit and the sow
returns to its mire the burn fool's
bandaged finger goes wobbling back to
the fire as kipling would write um but
um you know uh it was a miserable time
for a lot of people now i was blessed
because my folks were teachers so they
ultimately didn't lose their livelihoods
um and uh you know we were able to we
had a modest upbringing but i would
never have called myself poor
um and my folks worked hard to make sure
we could play hockey and
enjoy life and go on camping trips so um
i'm not uh i would not cry poor but uh
it was a modest upbringing one i'm very
proud of and one i'd like to pass on to
my kids as well how old were you when
you got interested in politics and what
were you like in high school
well i was a scrappy kid who loved
sports and then i got a terrible
tendinitis in my shoulder which made it
impossible for me to do any amateur
wrestling or football or any other
sports that i enjoyed
so i'd get home from school and be bored
out of my skull
my mom used to go and attend progressive
conservative meetings
uh and so i said why don't you take me
to one of these meetings because i've
got nothing to do
and she took me and i fell in love with
it and i just started
reading books uh all kinds uh about oh
god you should do that
i'm still recovering from and uh so why
in the world were you attracted to
conservatism because that's not a
particularly what would you say it's not
necessarily an attractive proposition
for the typical young person although
you know maybe something could be done
about that
so but what attracted you to
conservative philosophy
it was a bit of a winding road i started
off by reading a lot of left-wing
books and commentary
and was very very briefly persuaded by
that but then i stumbled on a book
called capitalism and freedom
by milton friedman
and
i
you know i didn't agree with a hundred
percent of what he wrote i still don't
however the fundamental logic of the
free market system
to me is inescapable okay what is that
logic as far as you're concerned
why is that why is it inescapable
because
in a free and open market you can't get
ahead unless you make someone else
better off
so i use the old um apple orange eye
analogy if you have an apple
and want an orange and i have an orange
and one in apple and we trade we're both
better off even though we still have an
apple in orange between us
it's like when you go to a coffee shop
and you buy a coffee you say thank you
to the lady who gave it to you and then
she says not you're welcome
but she says thank you back
now why is that well the answer is
because each of you has something
has gained something more valuable than
you had before
you have the cup of coffee that's worth
more than the 250 you paid for it the
coffee shop has the 250. and why do you
think the free part of that is important
so that's the trade part why is the free
part important
because that's the only way to guarantee
both people sides believe they're better
off right because in in the form of in
taxation
government forcefully
uh imposes a transaction it is
considered to be a transaction tax taxes
right you're paying for a whole plethora
of services
but you didn't choose it so even if
you've decided that the cost of your tax
bill
is not worth the benefit of the
government services you have to pay it
anyway
whereas back to the coffee shop
you have to if you don't believe the
coffee's worth more than the money you
won't pay it and if they don't believe
the money money's worth more than the
coffee they won't they won't sell it um
so the only way in a market system to
make yourself better off is to make
someone else simultaneously better off
so why did you now look lots of young
people in it today
either are not exposed to the ideas that
you just put forward or they don't find
them persuasive say in contrast to what
appears on the surface to be the more
compassionate left-wing view that's
characterized frequently and sometimes
realistically you know by concern for
the working class like i worked for the
ndp when i was a kid and at that time in
alberta grant naughtly ran the ndp and
he was an old union guy in some
fundamental sense and so were most of
the people he associated with you know
and they they did have a real concern
for the working class at least some of
them did and i would say that was
particularly true the leadership not so
much the activists but
you know you were pretty young when you
came across friedman i didn't have that
uh experience when i was say the same
age as you
why did you find that persuasive in
contrast to the left-wing ideas the
ideas of socialism this rooted in this
hypothetical compassion that seems so
attractive to kids today
because i didn't see the compassion
playing itself in any out in any uh real
way it was
it's a it's a catch phrase
um but
um what is god what we're actually
debating is not who's more compassionate
and there's no evidence that people on
the socialist left are especially
generous with their own money sure they
like to spend other people's money but
what you see is really uh with socialism
is uh
animal house playing itself out over and
over again
uh you know when the
animal farm excuse me animal farm
playing itself overnight definite
differences
definite difference animal farm uh you
know the pigs didn't say they wanted to
take the house so that they could be
more comfortable and spoiled they said
they were doing it to make everyone
equal and to remove the oppression
but then when the when they actually
took the house they basically they
became the new masters and served
themselves
and that's what you act that's what
actually happens in socialism it doesn't
eliminate hierarchy so why did you why
did you buy that argument was it for as
a consequence of encountering orwell as
well or
i think it's because i witnessed it
again and again
um in as i was i studied what actually
happens in socialist models it became
very clear
that the rhetoric about
economic equality never actually came to
pass it was used as a tool to mobilize
the masses
but ultimately
the outcome was to give
concentrate power more
in the hands of the political elite look
government is really legalized force um
so if you believe in big government you
believe in expanding force
relationships of force always favor the
powerful
and in re so in reality those who have
more political power than benefit from a
bigger government and those people are
all rich
right they are disproportionately
powerful in the system and so when this
big beast called government gets bigger
and more powerful those who have the
ability to
steer that beast are the ones who are
going to profit from it
so what do you what do you think of the
success of countries like the
scandinavian countries let's say well in
the relative success of canada because
there's been a fair solid socialist
influence more the english socialist
type than
the communist derived type fair
socialist influence in canada and it's
formed some of our fundamental
institutions our health care system our
pension system a fair bit of labor
legislation i mean when you look at and
then of course the scandinavian
countries small though they are and
homogenous though they are they're quite
radically successful in in in function
so what what do you make of that and how
do you how do you balance that against
your emphasis on well more conservative
philosophy and and your your support of
the freest markets possible in some
sense
all right so uh let's start with the
scandinavians i mean there's some really
uncomfortable facts about the
scandinavian countries that the left
would not like to talk about like
norwood 25 of norway's economy is oil
so
that's really tough to grapple with if
you're a modern socialist
moving to the other countries
sweden
welcomes all kinds of free enterprise
and choice including in the provision of
public services
and
they have in fact in the in the 90s the
swedes moved quite dramatically to
reduce the cost of government and open
up markets and and free enterprise so
it's not as simple as to say that that
these countries are socialistic and
therefore successful
um and yeah i think it was even the day
one of the danish leaders came to you to
the united states and
he was speaking at harvard and um he was
saying you know he was all the socialist
kids were expecting him to pump his fist
in the air and
and champion socialism he said no
actually
we're not a socialist country um and so
um
you know there's no question they
they definitely do have a strong social
safety net and i don't i don't object to
that um but i wouldn't say that they are
state commanded economies like like
we're seeing trudeau uh attempt to adopt
here in canada right so you see this is
variation within the free market world
right i do variation like there is
between the democrats and the
republicans in the u.s but fundamentally
it's a free market
everything is a question of degree
but you know there's a lot of academic
literature that shows that government
that countries with smaller governments
as a share of gdp tend to have less
poverty
and better social and economic growth
outcomes um and that is true in both the
developing world and the developed world
so i i do believe that you can provide a
solid social safety net
at the same time as having a powerful
free market economy that generates the
wealth
to fund that safety net
okay so you you got interested in
politics were you a popular kid in high
school would you say
um off and on there were times when i
was interested in hanging out and being
part of the club but there were other
times where i just didn't care i went
once i got involved in politics i
couldn't care less about uh the social
life at high school anymore
how old were you how old are you were
you when that transition took place you
said that was also
six years 16 17 like i said i kind of
wasn't able to do any more sports and so
i said
you know i'm going to go do something
else and once i i took that part of my
life took off
you didn't look at the social right no i
i had like a lot of my early teens i'd
been i loved hanging out with my friends
and playing sports and stuff but once uh
once i found a new passion i became more
focused on that how did that influence
your choice of education when you went
off to university and that that was it
did you say university calgary
that's right yes um yeah i wanted to do
a generalist
uh liberal arts kind of program and so i
did international relations which had
some econ a lot of history
uh some strategic studies a little bit
of poli sci
and
and it was a good over it was a good
overview a jack of all trades kind of
bachelor of arts um and it worked well
and was that in
in hypothetical service of your
political ambitions at that point or had
they catalyzed
i don't know that my political ambitions
were clearly defined at that point i
just knew i was generally interested in
politics and that
international relations would give me an
overview of almost all parts of the of
that one confronts in a political
environment did you have a conception of
a career path at that time
or i mean not people don't you know they
go to take a bachelor of arts they have
an interest and i'm and i'm not saying a
career path you know specifying one is
necessary i'm just curious as to what
what how you envisioned your future when
you were
pursuing your degree and and then what
happened afterwards
i'm trying to remember exactly but i i
don't think i knew exactly what paths i
was going to take i just knew that i
wanted
to fight for certain things that i
believed in
and that that would that would probably
take me into the political theater
were you active in campus politics
yeah i was involved with the campus uh
it was then the campus
progressive conservatives and reform
party
and involved in the debate club and
stuff like that you have a place called
speaker's corner it's like three floors
um of balconies where people could look
down and someone would stand on a big
stool in the middle and shout out a
speech and the speaker's corner would
meet every friday and there'd be lots of
heckling and it was just a rowdy affair
and but mostly mostly about hilarity and
joking around and giving silly
ridiculous addresses
and
that was a that was the friday tradition
we'd go and
belt out these speeches uh to sometimes
70 or 80 students would come and take in
these speeches and i i i imagine what if
we had the phone cameras back then
they'd probably be circulating wildly on
the internet right now no doubt god what
a horrible fate they have everything you
do when you're young recorded and never
forgotten so yeah well you seem to have
a sense of humor about such things too
and you're kind of viciously satirical
in the house of commons and so what what
role do you think having a sense of
humor plays in what you do
i think it's important i try to remember
it because
politics is a combat sport
but
there has to be some joy in it as well
and you have to make people feel good
you know the rabbi hillel
said
people won't always remember what you do
or what you say but they'll always
remember how you made them feel
and so i think it's important to make
people feel good uh when you're giving a
political speech make them you know
there's a tendency to get up and and sh
and spill doom and gloom all over the
room but i think it's important to make
people feel good about the moment and
also good about the future
and the most powerful way to do is is
humor well this is very interesting to
me because you've got a lot of people
coming out to your rallies and that i
should let everyone know who's
listening internationally that's not
really a canadian thing there have been
times when that's occurred but it's not
run-of-the-mill but you have a lot of
people coming to your rallies and you've
been attacked fairly viciously i would
say by the press for the nature of the
despicable people that you're attracting
you know otherwise known as canadians
and so
how what is it that you're doing that's
working to attract people and is it
related to this sense of humor and and
to an optimism that you're projecting
despite you know some of the dire things
that might be characterizing the
canadian state
i think it's um
i think people are desperate for hope in
canada right now
um
these uh these rallies have been really
emotional events like
um
people come with um incredible stories
and i do this thing after every speech i
i
plant myself in front of my
sign and i just let everyone come up one
by one and talk to me
and
i don't think the political class in
this country appreciates how much
suffering there is in canada right now
um
well they did get honked on out a lot
you know and that's pretty rough yeah
you know yes they've had i mean the
political class has had a wonderful two
years they have an unbelievable amount
of power
and a tremendous amount of comfort all
of their homes have gone up by 50 in
value
and their stock portfolios up until
recently have been inflated
and so they're sort of looking at down
at the working class and saying oh what
are you complaining about isn't you've
never had it so good well
that's the
the exact opposite uh has been true for
the working folks if you don't own a
home
you're um purchasing your like if you
didn't have a home before
2019
likelihood is you'll never own one
unless and until there's a major
reduction in housing prices
and so you've got this whole generation
of people of young people who have
concluded that they'll never be able to
afford homes they're 32 years old living
in their mom's basement you can imagine
the psychological impact that has on
someone's personal security
like how do you start a family so people
come to my rallies and they're looking
for an explanation
about why things are the way they are
and looking for some hope about how we
might make them better the the situation
doesn't make sense to people because
like i have one go you know what perfect
example
um
there's a guy living in the south end of
my riding south ottawa
and he has the same job that his mother
has and he ironically works at the same
desk that she worked at when she was
there
yet she was able to buy a house in south
ottawa
40 years ago
that he could not even dream of
affording today
and so what he's saying i wait a sec how
does this make sense i thought we were
supposed to be getting better off and
now after 40 years our family is far
worse off and i'm stuck in my parents
basement and i can't get married i can't
start a family i i don't even i don't
know where my life is going and so
they're coming they see me actually
explaining why this is happening and
then offering solutions
and they say to me that i'm actually
giving them a sense of hope
that's the number one word i hear from
people when they come up to me in the
line they say we feel like we have hope
again so that's what's bringing people
out okay so
you're listening to people one of the
things i've learned about
good politicians
and i know people think that's an
oxymoron but that's not an acceptable
amount of cynicism in my estimation
they and i think this was really true of
preston manning for example they're
really good at listening
and if they listen then people tell them
what their problems are and so you just
focused on housing and housing crisis
for young people when you're talking to
people individual to individual what's
tugging at your heartstrings and and and
making you understand the problems apart
housing is a big one obviously what else
do you hear and what's really concerning
you people feel like they've lost
control of their lives
um whether it's the the people who
have made a decision not to get
vaccinated for their own reasons and
have been
had uh had the government basically
steal their livelihoods
prevent them from getting on an airplane
ban them from ever leaving the country
um
or whether it's the you know single mom
who's skipping meals or kids don't have
to or you know the guy who can't fill up
his tank to go and drive and see his
parents for one last time before they
die in
in thunder bay
um people feel like they can't make the
normal decisions that a free
person could could make in a free
society
and
there's devastating personal
consequences to it and then what they
hear from the government is they speak
out right they speak out they hold a
protest they post something online
instead of the prime minister saying you
know what
i know you're suffering i'm sorry we're
going to work harder to make your life
better we hear you
um i feel your pain what he says is
you're a nasty unacceptable
fringe element and not only are we going
to seize your bank account
and uh and bring in the emergencies act
uh we're also going to double down on
the sa on the things that have made your
life so miserable in the first place
and so people people feel like they're
under attack from a big
bullying government that takes their
money and tells them what to do and what
they see in my campaign is that an
opportunity to take back control of
their lives
to remove the gatekeepers so that we can
build affordable housing to um
unleash the the energy sector so our
working class can get good jobs again to
stop the money printing and bring
inflation back down so folks can afford
things again um and that gives them hope
that there's actually a better day
coming and that's why we're attracting
so many people well so why do you think
it's it's so interesting listening to
you because
you know your
your your your narratives
center around the individual
individuals who make up the working
class the working class under duress and
isn't necessarily
the way in that you might
regard as most probable for a
conservative
you know and so why is it so i think
that's extremely interesting and in this
upside down world of ours why is it
though do you think that people
find
you
capable of delivering hope and i mean
there's other candidates on the
conservative front we should talk about
that soon but what makes you credible on
the hope front do you think in terms of
your what you're offering and who you
are
because i speak clear
plain language
that makes sense to people
so
you know i'm i'm a believer in
using
simple
um anglo-saxon words
that
strike right at the
the meaning that i'm trying to convey
and
so i say things that people say yeah
that actually makes sense so that folks
say well why is it why is inflation
running rampant and i explained to them
in
direct language
that when you print more money you have
more dollars chasing fewer goods it
leads to higher prices
folks say yeah that actually makes sense
isn't that what we were taught in grade
school
and
the explanations they get from everyone
else are a bunch of convoluted
nonsensical
um irrational
uh excuses
um and so
they they like my direct blunt style not
because it's simplistic but because it's
simply true
so what do you like about political life
it's a rough life and you take a lot of
flack i mean
obviously from your bio and i think from
the way you comport yourself it's
obvious that you've you've got the the
constitution to some degree of a fighter
which is i think would say something i
lack um but what is it about your what
is it about you that that attracts you
to the political on the in terms of the
interpersonal domain you talked about it
intellectually in some sense you know
these and you you talk a little bit
about your care for people one-on-one
but you like to listen apparently and
like why do you care about
ordinary people and why should people
believe that you care
well i think that um
i
wha what what bothers me most about
politics in canada is that there's a
comfortable establishment
that sits on top
and governs for itself
at everyone else's expense
and that the people who do the nation's
work
um the plumber the electrician the truck
driver
uh
the police officer
have almost no share of voice
um i want
to empower those people
and disempower the political
establishment
and that's my mission it's my purpose
and i believe in it i actually do
believe in what i say
i i truly believe that the ideas and the
political approach that i advance are
right
so
having that purpose
allows me to persevere through all of
the nastiness
and the exhaustion of political life
because if you don't believe in it then
it just becomes an egotistical vanity
project
of which there are many in politics
but it seems to me to be a a pointless
life all you're doing is trying to
advance trying to keep your name in the
news and in high office as long as
possible just so that you can say you
were there
um i i think you if to have a fulfilling
political career you actually have to
have a purpose
and i do my purpose is very simply i
want to put people back in charge of
their own lives
i don't want the state to run people's
lives anymore i want them to be masters
of their own destiny
okay so so let's drill down into that a
little bit so i would ask you two things
one would be
you know i'll prove i'll put a little
bit of a pro drama in front of it i
watched the federal leadership debate in
the last election and i thought the
conservatives lost before they opened
their mouths because they accepted the
diagnosis that was brought to the table
there were five topics of conversation
if i remember correctly and two of them
were basically progressive talking
points you know one was truth and
reconciliation another was climate
change there was 20 minutes devoted to
the economy you know and i thought you
guys made a big mistake because you left
you let the progressive types define the
questions and so i would say because it
may be the diagnosis in some sense is
more important than the cure at least
you know that you know you've got your
finger on the problem and so when you
look at canada
at the moment
what are our problems
the the central underlying illness is a
monstrous growth in the power and cost
of the state
at the expense of the agency and freedom
of the people
that is the the override now you can i
can then give specific examples of how
that outputs led so let's just take
let's just take monetary policy so
there's no way justin trudeau could get
away with spending uh all of the money
he has in the last two years if he had
to use real cash because people would
never accept the
many thousands of dollars of tax
increases that it would require so he
has basically turned our central bank
into an
atm machine
for his spending they've created 400
billion dollars of new money in two
years which has given us a 30-year high
in inflation and bumped up boosted real
estate prices by 50 percent how does
that compare to previous expense
expenditures by governments well it's
not even there it's not off the charts
if you look at the balance sheet of the
bank of canada during the harper area
even during the great global recession
there was a minor bump in the assets it
held which is represented which
indicates that you know how how much uh
money it was injecting whereas right now
it's it's shot off the charts uh so
the balance sheet of the central bank is
up something like 350 percent
and
all that cash is particularly ballooned
asset prices that's the unspoken story
here everyone thinks about consumer
inflation which is horrible as it is
then there's asset price inflation and
what that's doing is creating kind of an
aristocratic economy
where people with where the bigger the
asset you have or before the inflation
the richer you've become after it
and um it is almost like the housing is
is attached to a balloon and it's being
lifted higher and higher up and anybody
who's not already in the house will
never be able to grab it and get inside
and so we're but but it is all the
result of this massive expansion of the
money supply
um and uh so we're basically seeing a
transfer of wealth from the the
have-nots to
the have yachts as i like to say um
and and and those in the managerial
class uh the ceos whose stocks have been
artificially inflated and they've been
able to give themselves a
share buybacks with with exceptionally
low interest rates they can borrow
money and then buy back shares which
increases share value and gives them a
bonus
the the folks who own mansions and
protected in neighborhoods that are
protected by zoning laws against anyone
else moving in
these people have done exceptionally
well
over the last two years um and yet the
people who are doing the nation's work
are now having their salaries destroyed
by inflation um you know and then at the
local level you have municipalities
bringing in our zoning laws that prevent
new construction
so that you have artifact they're
invisible gates they're gated
communities but they're invisible gates
and the the invisible gate is government
bureaucracy that prevents construction
so we have fewer houses per capita than
any country in the g7 even though we
have the most land to build on um so
what i'm proposing in both cases stop
printing money start building houses i'm
going to tell the big city
mayors that if they don't remove their
bureaucratic zoning rules and let
builders build then i'm going to cut
back on some of their infrastructure
funds
because i think it's going to
need something that drastic to get these
gatekeepers out of the way and actually
build houses so that our youth have a
place to call home um and uh you know
but it's across the economy ironically
all of these big government
interventions seem to hurt the most
disadvantaged our immigrants come here
as doctors and engineers but they can't
work in those fields because of
occupational licensing uh protectionism
um they're the gatekeepers so i want to
incentivize provinces to speed up
recognition of foreign credentials so an
immigrant doctor can actually work as a
doctor
and remove the gatekeepers from our
energy sector so we can build pipelines
and
and
dig for resources and become energy
self-sufficient
and then remove the gatekeepers in
speech and you know all about those you
know the government is now pushing new
censorship laws on the internet um and i
promise very clearly that i'm going to
get rid of all of those laws and restore
uh freedom of expression on the internet
so really what i see is um the need to
remove the governmental gatekeepers to
restore our freedom let people take back
control of their lives
okay so
let's delve into economic policy a bit
so the oecd recently predicted
this is lovely that canada's economy
will be the worst performing advanced
economy over 2020 to 2030
and then three decades after now
it ha we haven't been doing very well as
a country not only under the liberals we
weren't doing that great at before under
the conservatives as well you know
especially compared to the us and many
other
and many other countries that in some
sense are peers and so
that's a pretty damn gloomy forecast
right 40 years out we're going to be the
worst performing advanced economy in the
world
and so
what do you what what do you think the
conservatives conceivably did wrong in
the past to
fail to stave that off and what do you
think you can do differently and maybe
we can make so you're interested in
housing you're interested in
deregulation especially on the housing
front i want to focus in as we progress
through this part on energy in
particular because that's a killer
topic for everyone in the world at the
moment i would say so what did the
conservatives do wrong what has canada
done wrong
what what have the liberals done wrong
apart from you know printing money like
mad men and instituting these arbitrary
rules and what do you think you can do
differently
right well i i would respectfully
disagree on the conservative economic
track record if you look at the 07
financial sorry the os 0809 financial
crisis we came through better than any
of the other g7 countries certainly way
better than the americans we didn't have
a housing crash here we didn't have a
banking crisis we didn't have to bail
out a single bank
we had very modest inflation i don't
think it ever cracked four percent uh
and i don't think it was above three
percent for more than one or two
quarters in the entire 10-year period
harper was around and unemployment
stayed
relatively low you could buy the average
house when harper left office in canada
was 434 thousand dollars
it's kind of hard to imagine that now um
but
um on a fast forward to energy
we need to repeal c69 that's the bill
that makes it effectively impossible to
build an energy project in canada today
um because it has introduced a whole
series of
sociological questions that uh that into
the um
process that no that make sense to
nobody um you know trudeau has said that
energy projects uh are
uh cause gender imbalances and therefore
when someone applies to build one they
have to write a sociological report on
what their what the pipeline or
the uh mine will do for gender relations
uh well with that intro in addition to
being
sort of ridiculous um
um
pop culture so sociology
it introduces massive
uncertainty for investors because they
don't really know how and why a project
will be approved or rejected
and they they don't have seven years to
sit around so they'll take their money
and invest it in other parts of the
world
and that's why the projects aren't
happening here we don't mind lithium in
canada even though we have lots of
lithium in this electric car battery uh
era you know we're but we're importing
lithium
from china
because they actually get projects built
however they burn coal to refine their
lithium so ironically we're just
inducing pollution in other countries
when we buy electric cars that are made
in whose lithium is is
refined in that country so if we could
approve a lithium mine in canada we
could actually mine the stuff refine it
manufacture it here we have the third
biggest supply of oil on planet earth
but we're importing 130 000 barrels of
overseas oil every day
the solution to which is so obvious is
that right next door to the saint john
uh port where we bring in the port of
the the oil we have st john's
newfoundland uh is uh capable of adding
another
400 000 barrels of canadian production
we could just approve that production
that we could ban foreign oil overseas
oil from canada all together and that
would mean that the dollars wouldn't be
leaving our country for overseas
dictatorships but would be staying here
paying canadian wages instead um and uh
natural gas we got 1 300 trillion cubic
feet of natural gas and you know what
you do you know you you get natural gas
onto a ship you have to freeze it down
to a liquid what do we have in canada
cold weather as you know
and uh so it takes a hell of a lot less
energy to liquefy natural gas in canada
finally an advantage for cold weather
finally an advantage
uh and uh and yeah and we have also
geographic advantage we're the closest
point in north america to asia is bc the
closest point in north america to europe
is is newfoundland so we have a shorter
shipping distance less energy needed to
liquefy gas and yet we haven't succeeded
in building a single
major liquefaction facility in canada
despite the fact that in 2015 there were
about 18 proposed projects so you could
approve those projects we could be
bringing a hundreds of billions of
dollars of opportunity to our people
particularly our first nations people
but it takes getting those regulatory
gatekeepers out of the way to let it
happen
what makes you think you could take on
the woke crowd in relationship to such
things so we could say well
um
what about the planet what about the
climate crisis you're going to turn back
to fossil fuels you're going to demolish
the
globe in the next 30 years we should be
moving towards net zero you're going to
doom the poor to catastrophe while
you're pretending to elevate them
economically it's like and you're going
to be like cut into ribbons by that
crowd and so
let's talk about climate change and the
paris accords and all that you we want
to promote you want to promote canadian
energy
there's a foreign policy reason for
doing that you made a case for
liquefication like exactly what should
canada's position be in relationship to
climate change and then the development
of our energy infrastructure
well our resources are not the problem
they're the solution
for example we export our natural gas we
can displace
foreign coal burning electricity uh the
energy hungry asian markets are
desperate for non-coal sources of
electricity
but they need things like natural gas to
replace it coal with
and we have that gas we also have the
biggest supply of civilian grade uranium
in the world right in saskatchewan that
could be used to export to regenerate
emissions-free pollution-free
nuclear energy we have an over-abundance
of hydroelectricity in manitoba and
quebec that we could be exporting to the
northern united states to displace their
coal-fired electricity uh we have we
could be using small modular nuclear
reactors
to uh de-carbonize the electrical grid
for the oil sands and uh and we have the
the the ability to do that right here in
canada we have carbon the carbon and
capture and storage
techniques in in our home province of
alberta are second to none um there are
some you know white cap resources a
mid-sized company there
says that it's actually a now a carbon
negative company in other words they
bury more carbon in the ground than they
put into the air
and so we have the technology and the
resources to do it but we're right now
what we're doing is punishing
our own resource sector to the advantage
of heavily polluting foreign
dictatorships with no
environmental standards
and who use the money to do great mal
and so we would be better off to
displace their energy with ours
and use that as a method of fighting for
the environment while enhancing the
well-being of our working class at the
same time
well so if this optimistic view is true
which is a view that basically says in
some sense we can have our cake and
share it with others and eat it too
right because we can make progress on
the economic front and on the climate
front
at the same time and i would like to
point out that america's turn to natural
gas has knocked their carbon dioxide
output substantially down over the last
15 years is which is not a statistic you
hear from the typical environmentalist
types okay so if we the world could turn
to canadian energy and as a consequence
the net cos the net impact on the carbon
economy would be positive in in meaning
reduce reducing carbon carbon dioxide
output and we could get wealthier in
doing so then why in the world aren't
the liberals already doing this if if
the pathway forward is so clear and
they're concerned about the environment
in some genuine sense and also let's say
secondarily about economic matters is
there something wrong with your
reasoning that they know that's made
this impossible or how do you understand
the fact that this isn't already
happening
you know it is hard to understand i
think that
it goes in line their their
environmental
policies seem more designed to give the
state more control of the economy
than they are designed to deliver an
environmental outcome
um they
the by attacking the energy sector
it gives them the ability to to create
more of a command and control economy
which is what they believe in
and
to redistribute wealth between
industries and towards political friends
in a very parasitical manner
but you know we have a total
uh nut as our environment minister right
now stefan gilbeau
he is bonkers
and he he
he's against nuclear
it's not just oil and gas he would get
rid of nuclear as well so
i don't know what would be left like you
can't well you know all you have to do
to get electricity is put a plug in the
wall yeah
that's right out it comes you know
plentiful i don't know why i'm over
complicating it here i don't know either
and yeah yeah
so it is quite quite a mystery to me all
of this the fact that that because i do
believe at least to some degree that the
reality that you put forward is actually
valid that we could have our cake and
eat it too i certainly think the
americans have managed that
as they've turned to fracking and
and have become a net exporter of fossil
fuel i can't see that that's done the
damn world one bit of harm and
well in this situation with russia is
one of the things that shows just how
foolish we are and depending on well
countries other than
say
standard reliable forward moving uh
stable democracies like canada
so be lovely if that could all occur so
okay so let's turn away from economic
policy just for a moment why do you
think the press in canada
is so dislikes you to such a degree
and are there exceptions to that rule
well there are exceptions that i find
the independent media gives me a fair
shake um but uh and there are some
columnists even in in the mainstream
publications that are fair and
reasonable
but
the political media in the parliamentary
press gallery are part of the
establishment
and that defines me threatening because
i'm upsetting the apple card um they are
part of the ecosystem of big government
um they and when it comes to the cbc
they are big government their entire
um budget comes from government
um and the corporate
owner we might we might want to tell our
international
listeners and viewers just how big a
subsidy the cbc gets every year and what
the cbc is and then we can talk about
media subsidies in general and the
collusion between the federal government
and the canadian media establishment so
maybe we start with cbc it's 1.2 billion
a year right in that range yeah it's 1.2
billion to produce a negligible audience
a very very small audience
and produce almost no original
content that you couldn't find somewhere
else
but the what this does is creates a
massive state-funded ecosystem
and
even the journalists who don't work for
cbc
they get these contracts to comment on
cbc this they go on these panels and
they get paid i'm told three four five
hundred bucks a pop to go and offer
their opinion
and this so as a result they all want to
regurgitate the acceptable state
uh generated opinion
and then they uh
so it basically creates uh a monolithic
ideology and political narrative
uh that comes from the center of the
government and is designed to uphold uh
the trudeau government to keep them in
power for as long as possible um and so
yeah i'm running against that and is
that going to be hard absolutely they're
going to do everything they can to tear
me apart
i have no doubt about that
would you defund the cbc yes you've made
that claim you you absolutely would do
that yes even though okay so let me push
back against that for a bit okay because
this is an important question to me
because i'm not very fond of the cbc
especially
as it's managed itself over the last
decade let's say i used to watch it a
lot when i was a kid i used to listen to
cbc radio a lot too and i thought it was
a reasonably credible and reliable
purveyor of information i think those
those days are long gone in any case
many conservative politicians in canada
have made
gestures in that direction you know and
then the the people who are going to
come after are going to say well you
know you're not a fan of canadian
culture and because of the overwhelming
influence of the united states and
foreign media we need to subsidize
canadian journalistic and it and and
entertainment activities because
otherwise we'll have nothing at all and
generally what happens is the cbc
continues to
survive regardless of government so what
makes you what makes you think you do it
and how do you think you could survive
and this is back to that question before
right how do you think you can push back
against the woke types who are so good
at savaging reputation and interfering
with the kind of well policies that
you're trying to put forward
so on the cbc there was a time when you
could make an argument for
a market failure you could say look here
we are american culture is so massive
and noisy um
competing it with it is like trying to
have an argument with a marching band
right it's just so loud and it'll just
drown out everything in canada but
that that was only the case because
the massive cost of production and
distribution
made it very hard for canadian talent to
even get on with the airwaves without
some assistance
but now
there are almost there are like the cost
of production and distribution of
culture
information and content is negligible i
mean any
teenager
with
you know seven or eight hundred bucks um
can use his or her phone
to start producing content put it online
if people want to see it
um
or any disgraced university professor
that's right
but uh no i mean like the reality is
that um
you know if you had a if you if you were
a canadian artist in 1980 you didn't
have the capital to compete with
hollywood now you actually don't need a
lot of capital um and so with the free
and open internet uh
anyone can break through as long as they
have a willing audience so the reason
that cbc's content requires subsidy is
not because of some market failure
it's because it's not appealing to
canadians
well that's just because canadians
aren't smart enough to appreciate it you
know well that's the narrative right
you know that and that's the irony about
the canadian media today
they think their job is to hold the
people accountable to the government
rather than the government accountable
to the people
so what about other media subsidies
what's your policy on that because
during covid in particular but over the
last few years you know
obviously print journalists have taken a
beating from the internet because well
for the same reasons you just outlined i
mean it what do you think is there a
rule for the subsidy of the press in
canada
and if there is a rule what is it and if
not what would you do
well i haven't uh uh
the trudeau policies are
definitely designed to
basically make the entire media
apparatus dependent on the goodwill and
the good um yet the good will of the
state um they have a
government uh bureaucracy that
determines what is considered to be a
qualified
journalistic uh company
and they pick and choose uh based on
their own political views who then
qualifies and therefore gets the subsidy
i think this is designed to
again create more dependency on the
government and curry more favor with the
state
um
i haven't made an announcement on
exactly how i'm going to fix that
problem yet
but i but i guess i would say stay tuned
on that i i want to de-politicize
that and basically restore the freedom
of the press in this country again
by getting the state out of it
so you're at least philosophically
opposed to the idea of
let's call it government press collusion
and might take see that part of the
problem is i think that once you obtain
power let's say
the temptation
to have the media under your thumb in
some sense as a consequence of such
subsidies you can see how that would
tempt people right i think it's it's
very useful to be cognizant of the sorts
of temptations that do beset someone as
they
acquire a position of authority and
power and this is why i want to push
hard on the cbc issue because it's a
signal issue it would be quite a
dramatic move to defund the cbc because
it has been a standard bearer in some
sense of a whole vision of canadian
culture and so that would that would
send a powerful message like if if they
do have such an incredibly loyal
audience
then they can support themselves through
their audience like other institutions
do i mean
uh you know there are
countless other journalistic
organizations that support themselves
through subscriptions sponsorship
advertising and other means
and i think that's what we we need to do
with cbc if they genuinely have an
audience then they can go get support
from their audience i don't i know
there's lots of publications to which i
subscribe i don't ask the taxpayer to
pay for my subscriptions i pay for it
out of my pocket and i watch either that
or i suffer the advertising um but i
don't expect that other people are going
to pay for me
to uh
consume the media that i like so why
should i why should other canadians be
forced to pay
for this far left uh liberal propaganda
that that
makes up most of cbc's coverage
all right well it'd be it'll be
interesting to see what all comes that
that should make uh it's even some more
friends on the journalistic front so but
you know
that's the thing people say well you're
gonna you're picking a fight with cbc
they're gonna come after you in the next
election well they went after harper
they went after sheer they went after
o'toole what we found is that by not
proposing
to defund them they're just as vicious
uh as they were what would otherwise be
they campaigned full time to get justin
trudeau elected prime minister even
though harper had run a 10-year
government without defunding them so
yeah they're going to come at me uh guns
blazing i know that but they would do
that even if i weren't taking the
principled stand on defunding them
right so so okay so that's that's a good
that's a good point you've got nothing
to lose on that front in some sense so
that's problem with depriving people of
theirs of their support for you you know
you can't take anything away when
there's nothing there to begin with
okay so let
if you don't mind um
let's turn to trudeau and to sing these
are your two
uh well the two people who will you'll
be facing off against in some real sense
and you do face off against quite
regularly in the house um
what do you think of mr trudeau
so i think he's an egomaniac
and i think everything he does is comes
back to his egomania
um even his political ideology you
really think about his his ex
expansionistic role of the state
um it never comes back to
[Music]
serving
an individual
objective other than to make him
more powerful or his legacy
more grand
so let me give you a few examples so he
he
slashed the amount you can put into a
tax-free savings account
but then he simultaneously increased the
amount you were forced to pay into the
state savings plan
he
um
killed multiple pipelines then he
invested state money
in a pipeline
he attacked parents ability to take care
of their own children by by removing tax
uh fairness for families of the
state-home parent
and then he brings in a government
program to replace it
um so what you're seeing there is you
say well this sounds like these are
utterly inconsistent positions and the
answer no they're not they're all very
consistent in all cases what he does is
takes away the ability of business or
individuals or families to do things for
themselves and it requires they do
things through him and through the state
um and
and
his ideology is always about creating
a pretext
in order to justify
the state garnering more control over
every aspect of your life
how you raise your kids how your
business functions
what you see and say on the internet he
believes the state has to be everywhere
always but that's because as uh king
louis would say
the state is him
well you know that that's okay so let's
i got a couple of things to throw at
that the first is you know i think it's
a very dangerous thing to attack the man
rather than the ideas but you're making
you know as a rule of thumb but you're
making a case that in this case that
can't be done because there is a
personality trait that is uniting
diverse policy decisions that isn't
ideational or ideological even it is in
fact personal and so my sense of truth
initially i was very upset with it with
his decision to run for prime minister
because i thought
well you don't know anything
and you're attractive and you can behave
well in public and you and you have
a charming facade
but you don't know anything in any real
sense and there's no and there's no
indication that you do you're not
particularly well educated and you're
not particularly accomplished and this
is actually a hard job but worse than
that
the only reason you even have the vagus
possibility of succeeding is because you
have the same last name as your father
and so and then he ran and i thought
well how do you justify that to yourself
because
the gap of knowledge must have been
painfully evident to him
and the fact that the trudeau name you
could you could say well you know the
liberal party came to me that's his
justification they came to me and there
wasn't another person that could win on
the liberal side and better a trudeau
liberal even if it's a consequence of
family name than any damn conservative
let's say but
i still saw it as a manifestation of a
really profound narcissism i think a
reasonable person would have said
i'm not prepared for this certainly not
yet and i'm not the man that need that
there needs to be in this position
so
i don't know what you think about those
musings but that's how i looked at
trudeau and i certainly haven't seen
anything in the preceding years that
has disabused me of any of those notions
i mean i think there's some truth in
that he is his victory was definitely
not a meritocratic one he was probably
the least vetted
prime ministerial candidate in our
history the media just glossed over so
much of his life
um to go straight to to help him and
protect him it was almost like they
built a protective cocoon
around him and uh and you know like
he had
he had
dressed up in grotesque racist costumes
so many times he says he by his own
claim he can't remember them all
i mean the average politician had done
that once it would have been exposed and
that person would have been expelled
from politics altogether
um you know
but uh you know he had run as a
middle-class champion even though while
he sheltered the millions he inherited
from his grandfather in a tax preferred
trust fund all these things would have
been front and center in the
public uh
sphere had it been anyone other than a
trudeau um and but he was protected by
it by the media who still protect him
because he really is their
camp candidate he he represents the
political class
and the establishment in canada uh those
who profit off a big um bloated
bureaucracy and regulatory state
um in
the the old uh upper canada era
aristocracy uh know that he will always
deliver for them and he has his
deliveries he's delivered mightily for
and that's why they're doing so well and
that's why they'll fight tooth and nail
to keep them there
why do you think he was and still
remains attractive to a substantial
subset of canadians i mean people seem
to regard him as
charming and caring and i think he is
charming in a kind of shallow sense
but it isn't obvious to me at all that
he's caring but he
he seems to play the part and he plays
it well enough so that
while many people
and this is true of people all over the
world certainly by the
by the act so why do you think that is
and
and how do you combat that
yeah look he is charming i won't deny
that
um and he's a good-looking dude uh but i
don't think he's actually that popular
so people people forget he got
he got 32 percent of the vote in the
last election 68 of those who cast
ballots voted against him
that's the lowest he got the lowest
share of vote of any prime minister
in canadian history and before him the
record was set
by him in the previous election he got
33 percent of the vote um
he never actually reached the height uh
the vote share that harper got in 2011.
so
we we sometimes we think he's an
extremely popular guy because of the
adulation he gets from the mainstream
media but in fact he's not that popular
with ordinary canadians what he
succeeded at doing to his credit
is engineering a very efficient
distribution of votes so that with 32
percent of the vote i think he got
something like 45 or 46 percent of the
seats
um and that is the nut we need to crack
he wins a lot of seats with with with
few votes we win few seats with lots of
votes in fact the last two elections
conservatives have beat him in the
popular vote we just haven't got them in
the right places so we need to we need
that's the change we need to make and i
believe we will make in the forthcoming
election so you don't think that it is a
preponderance of canadians who have had
the wolf pulled over their eyes it's no
he's not by look by any objective
analysis of the data he's not an
especially popular prime minister um and
in fact he's probably
more on the side of an unpopular prime
minister what about mr jagmeet singh who
for our international watchers and
listeners is the leader of the canadian
socialist party and in some sense the
ndp new democratic party and in some
sense the person who holds the balance
of power right now in canada's house of
commons and therefore the keys in some
real sense to the federal government
what do you think about mr singh
well he lacks on that right why does he
exist you've already got an ndp prime
minister a socialist prime minister in
justin trudeau so that means the
socialist party has to try to figure out
what to do with itself
um and
um uh he is so so so far jagmeet has
said well he'll just support trudeau in
a coalition
and the problem is when you go back to
the elector electorate people are going
to say well you're part of the same
problem like i had a gentleman in um i
was in charge lee in quebec
lifelong ndp supporter
um very
upset with how life is the guy was
telling me he's had to reduce his his
diet to one meal a day because food is
so expensive
and he was voting for the ndp until he
signed the ndp formed a coalition with
trudeau the guy who's caused all the
misery it's gonna be very hard for
jagmeet to go to the people and claim
that he represents anything other than
the trudopian status quo and i think
that in the next election people will be
looking for a drastic departure from
trudeau so um they'll be looking for the
anti-trudeau and so what do you think of
him on the personal front i mean one of
the things that's really struck me about
sing apart from his
unconditional support for trudeau in
exactly the manner you described is that
he seems
almost
stunningly
and singularly devoid of ideas i haven't
seen anything come out of the ndp
federally that isn't just woke nonsense
that constitutes a genuine appeal let's
say to the working class and i also
thought that his we can talk about this
too his response to the truckers convoy
was something remarkable to behold
because here you had the party the
putative party of the oppressed working
class
if anything even more dismissive of that
protest than the liberals which is
really saying something because true as
you pointed out called them
misogynists and bigots and claimed
completely falsely with the collusion of
the cbc that the vast preponderance of
the money that funded that protest had
come first from the bloody russians and
then
from the like from the american
republicans who were apparently you know
trying to stage a coup in a country they
don't even really it isn't even really
on their radar for reasons that no one's
been able to
i was in the states you know for three
months i went to 50 cities in the last
three months
and i talked during the q a period about
because people kept asking what's going
on with canada and i said well you're
not going to believe this but our
government and our media have told
canadians that
mega
type republicans
basically tried to stage a coup to
destabilize our democracy and they would
ask and this was democrats and
republicans alike they would ask
but
why would we do that
what possible motive if we cared which
we don't why in the world would we
possibly want to destabilize canada's
democracy
and the answer to that is well i i
always felt as a representative
candidate in that situation i always
felt like i was in some sense out of my
mind because i couldn't believe that
i could present that
complex of ideas as a reality and that
there wasn't just something wrong with
the way i was looking at the whole
situation it's so utterly preposterous
so well back to mr singh he ned he
didn't support the truckers and at all
no in and the ndp has abandoned the
working class
uh they they become another party of the
elite
institutional aristocracy
uh that they represent um
the those with um
big salaries doing managerial work
um in my many of whom have been able to
work from home with fully protected
salaries and
incomes for the last two years
um which is fine i mean there's nothing
wrong with
having there's no i don't begrudge
anyone for having
had that good fortune but it certainly
if you are such a person
um then you shouldn't be judging those
who are protesting because they've lost
everything
over the last two years and you would
think that you know the ndp would have
actually stood for the downtrodden but
that is not what they really believe and
that goes back to what i was saying
earlier like you were saying you know
isn't it isn't that the left isn't the
socialist parties that really care about
the downtrodden and the disadvantage the
answer is of course not that is the
rhetoric what they really care about is
a powerful state and anyone who
threatens the state is the enemy and and
that's what we saw with jagmeet singh
you saw a group of people who were
independently raising their voices for
their freedom he said we can't have that
we're gonna i'm gonna
join with trudeau and call them a bunch
of horrible names um and and that's what
he did which is exactly the opposite of
what you're supposed to do if you really
care about working-class people
well they seem the the the people who
purported to to care for the working
class and this certainly happened with
the american democrats under clinton
seem perfectly willing to sacrifice the
economic interests of the real working
class those people who exist right now
to some hypothetical utopian future and
every time push comes to shove the real
working class takes a walloping hit in
the name of this hypothetical future
utopia you see that on the energy front
we talked about policy there and that's
certainly not only the case in canada
it's like it's like
a church show when he visited our home
province of alberta
and uh
he just
he saw the working classes in the energy
sector
and
his son
randolph said
said these are not uh
members of the cultural elite
and he said churchill said to his son
yes but the the elite are but the
glittering scum that floats upon the
river of production
yeah well i think i think maybe that was
part of the backlash against the
truckers you know because these real
people came out and said we got a
problem here with you guys you're
you're pushing us down a little too hard
and maybe you could stop doing it you're
fundamentally violating our civil
liberties and we might point out that
this is in a country that still does not
allow its citizens to travel
yes that's right and you know what what
i think the real backlash by the elites
against the truckers was a
this idea that truckers have no business
going to ottawa and raising their voices
that's that's the idea that that the
elites were trying to push back against
they want
they think that the working classes
should just shut up and pay up
and let the let the
um the experts
just
run things for us and and and provide
and with the population should provide
total deference to these institutional
elites to just run our lives for us and
uh do what we're told
now you stood up for the trucker so now
you've had some time it's been a couple
of months you've had some time to
consider your position and
so can you
tell me what you think happened with the
trucker protest and and then i'd like to
segue into the imposition of the
emergencies act which um
you know is grist for the mill let's say
in terms of discussion so
tell me tell me your response to the
trucker's protest in convoy and where
you stood and where you stand
so i
as i said before the truckers even
arrived on parliament hill
when media asked me about it
i support those peaceful law-abiding
truckers
who
came to ottawa
to peacefully protest for their
livelihoods and liberties and i
simultaneously condemn any individuals
who broke laws behave badly or blockaded
critical infrastructure i think it's
possible to hold individually
accountable
in bad actors without
painting every single person with the
same brush if you went to any protest
that had nine or ten thousand people you
will find bad actors
but that doesn't mean that all nine or
ten thousand are uh are themselves bad
actors um you know for example i was uh
confronted by a journalist the other day
said yes but what about those
journalists who sorry what about those
um those truckers that were angry at
journalists who behaved badly or
conducted themselves poorly uh what do
you say to them i said well they should
be individually held to account for
their behavior but he said well don't
you take some responsibility for
supporting the cause i said well let me
ask you this do you hold every single
environmentalist personally responsible
for the acts
wielding terrorists
who went to the coastal gaslink pipeline
construction site and started trying to
kill
pipeline workers does every single
person who's spoken out against
pipelines take personal responsibility
for what those ax-wielding terrorists
did
or are the t are the are the axe
wielders themselves personally
responsible and even i
would say no
you can criticize a pipeline i disagree
with you you can criticize a pipeline
without taking personal responsibility
for the violence of some eco-terrorist
you've never even met
um and so
i walked around i saw the truckers on
parliament hill by the way those who
most people weren't actually there the
media depiction was total nonsense if
you watched it on television you would
think that it was armageddon
um
jordan
every single member of parliament that
that condemned the truckers in the house
of commons during the protest had to
walk right through the tucker trucker
convoy right because they they were
parked right up front there was no way
to get in without walking through them
and not one of them were prevented from
from walking through
um it was peaceful it was most of the
time sort of a jubilant type celebration
um
and
people came and went they walked around
on parliament hill members of parliament
of all political stripes walked through
the protest every day without incident
and yes it was some some businesses were
inconvenienced and lost money they
should be compensated
but by and large it was a peaceful
protest
by people who generally don't get
involved in political activism they're
truckers they drive truck all day
yeah they have things to do man they
have things the other thing is what you
know why didn't they all go home after
the first week
jordan they had nowhere to go
because the government had taken away
their jobs they weren't allowed to go
back to their jobs you can imagine if
trudeau had just said we're going to
lift the mandate on the truckers they
would have fired up their machines and
hit the road to go back to work but he
took away their jobs and their
livelihoods no wonder they stayed there
for so long and it was absolutely
unscientific and malicious look
if anyone is
going to spread a virus as sure as
hell's not the guy who's sitting alone
by himself all day in a truck
so this was never about
medical science it was about political
science it was about demonizing a small
minority uh for political gain
and i'm i'm proud of the fact that
people stood up and fought for their
freedoms in that uh that case
yeah well there is a contempt associated
with that on the liberal and the ndp
side that was really quite striking to
see like really quite mind-boggling to
see and you know
the other thing that struck me about the
truckers because i talked to quite a few
of them also publicly when the protest
was occurring and suggested near the
time when they did decide to leave that
they should probably leave because the
crazies were going to show up and cause
trouble because i think if you occupy
anything if you protest long enough and
the people who want to cause trouble are
going to gravitate and i think they left
about exactly when they should and that
they reached a lot of their goals i mean
first of all they did blow up the
conservative party which i know they
didn't exactly intend to but that wasn't
nothing
and also um and maybe you disagree with
that interpretation but also canada
really started to move on the mandate
front pretty much at the same time the
truckers jumped up and down about it and
so i thought they did extremely well and
i also think the world responded that
way because that protest became a model
for similar and peaceful and useful
protests all across the world
so now do you what do you think happened
to the conservatives in the aftermath of
the trucker's protest am i being too
harsh or
no i look i i don't know that there's a
direct link between the two um but
i think um
i think by and large uh the concert it
was a difficult political challenge to
hot potato for any political party to
manage
um but
i can't speak for how everyone else in
the caucus managed it or commented on it
but i i'm happy with where i landed
um i
i pushed through the controversy and
stood my ground
and i i'm happy to say that i that my
position on that protest is exactly the
same as it was before it even arrived in
ottawa and i believe i can defend
everything i did and set on
i'm going to ask you one last question
i'd like to talk to you for about two
more hours but we can't do that and i
don't want to push the patients of the
viewers listeners either
let's talk about the emergencies act
so what do you have to say about that
well
i mean
it's ironic that trudeau brought in the
emergencies act
um
[Music]
after the the border crossings were
cleared of protest
which is the only you know the blockades
of the border were wrong i said so at
the time
the
but that being said they had been
resolved
by the time trudeau actually brought in
the emergencies act
and so what we effectively had at that
point was about
you know 10 or 11 blocks in downtown
ottawa
that were blocked by trucks
you know to put this into perspective
the emergencies act is sort of like a
war measures act almost it's almost kind
of like martial law
yeah a lot like it we haven't actually
done that in canada
since this law was actually instituted
his father did use the war measures act
to
a tackle um some
terrorist attacks by the by a radical
quebec separatist group but since that
time we've not done it even in 9 11
when 24 25 canadians were killed in a
terrorist attack in new york
or when a terrorist shot dead a soldier
at the war monument and then stormed
parliament spraying bullets around
in all directions we didn't use it then
um and so we we've never really used
this law you would think that it would
be used in a case where there was a
foreign invasion
or a monstrous terrorist attack
or something of that magnitude
but we never did and then we trudeau did
it for this protest i think he
ultimately
uh was um
just angry that he was personally facing
a political protest and didn't want to
uh to to to face the con the political
consequences of a democratic protest he
also wanted to be as
malicious as possible to deter any
similar protest so he he actually seized
bank accounts which caused a lot of
people to have fear that if they ever
donated to the wrong political cause
that the state might freeze their
account and shut them out of business
so um i think there's a lot of um
you know fear is a powerful political
tool and i think that's what he was
trying to invoke
with the use of this act
so what do you think should be done
about the fact that he did in fact
invoke it because this is a major league
suspension of civil liberties this along
with the fact that unvaccinated
canadians still can't leave the country
or fly within the country or take a
train
and i see no excuse whatsoever for the
imposition of those restrictions as of
now
it's maliciousness
it's vengefulness as far as i can tell
so
how how is the government going to be
held accountable when we have what's
essentially a coalition in place
well it's going to be hard i mean i
think it's going to have to be voters
that will hold them to account when we
finally have an election
but um they will you know they've
appointed a someone who was a former
liberal liberal staffer to be the
to to oversee the inquiry into the use
of the act
um i think uh we need i'm consulting
with scholars legal scholars on how we
can
curtail
the power and limit the use of the
emergencies act in the future
um i want to be very
careful though in how i do it because i
you know this is an incredibly
blunt instrument but it you know in
in times of war or foreign attack or
something like that
you could understand why there might be
an occasion where these powers might be
needed
so we need but i do think we need to
craft
changes to the act
that will prevent it from being abused
for political purposes like this again
so i said at the beginning i would be
mindful of your time in our private
conversation before we started and we
are unfortunately running out of time
and there's at least twice as many
things as we got to that i would like to
get to and so maybe we can do that in
the future so i'd like to give you the
opportunity at the end just to
well
is there anything we didn't talk about
today that's of signal importance that
you would like to bring up today and and
and and close with yeah i i would just
say um
you know i think that we're we're
divided right now in canada
because
of a deliberate strategy of divide and
conquer
governments that want to enhance their
control they have to turn citizens
against each other
they have to make you afraid of your
neighbor your co-worker your trucker
so that you'll turn to the state for
protection
against your fellow citizenry
and
that's the oldest trick in the book
divide and conquer
control
is by its definite by its nature
divisive because it's a zero-sum game if
one gets more control
another must have less
freedom is
not the is the quite the contrary
um if you your neighbor gets more
freedom
you don't get less freedom the
likelihood is you'll have more as well
so if your friend has more freedom of
speech well you'll have freedom of
speech if you are if the immigrant has
the freedom to work as a doctor
then you'll have the freedom to have a
doctor if the local small businessman
has the freedom to function without red
tape
then you'll probably have the freedom to
buy his products more affordably or your
teenager might get a job with the
freedom to have a job with them
you know if the muslim or jew gets more
religious freedom then the christian
gets more religious freedom and that's
why freedom is a unifying
principle it brings people together
because it allows each of them to be
masters of their own destiny without
taking anything from each other
we fight over control
whereas we fight for freedom
that is the difference and um i i
believe we can bind up the nation's
wounds by reinstating the
ancient freedoms that we inherited from
our ancestors
and so i really see my role as quite an
uh an unimportant one i'm here simply
restoring what can it already belong to
canadians
um by virtue of their 800-year
inheritance of
english liberties going back to the
magna carta
i'm just among the the common people who
are custodians of that freedom while
we're alive you know edmund burke said
it's a contract between the dead the
living and yet to be born
and we're the living generation has the
duty
to pass on that inheritance
and that's what i i see myself doing is
to
re-kindle that inheritance and pass it
on to
my kids and so they can pass it on to
their kids
and
i'll pass away into the
uh fade away into the the past one day
but hopefully we'll have secured the
freedom that we inherited for many more
generations to come and that's that's
what i mean when i want to give people
back control of their life in the
present it's also
um to extend it into the future
so that's my purpose that's why i'm
running i you know people want to
support me by
pierre4pm.ca
yes that's pierre four the number four
pm.ca is how you can sign up become a
member and do that and i would be
honored to have people's support in this
enterprise
mr pierre
olive
thank you very much for talking with me
today much appreciate it i hope we get a
chance to continue this conversation
there's many more things that
it would be a pleasure to jointly bring
to the attention of canadians so and i
would also say thank you for your
i think your courage in allowing me to
do this you know i've asked other
politicians including some on the
conservative side and i've had some
agree
um
to speak with me but
generally they seem intimidated by the
span of time that stretches out in front
of them or perhaps
you know not cognizant fully of the
power of youtube dialogue but um
you
well thank you very much for
participating and for talking to me much
appreciated thank you dr peterson i
really appreciate your uh prodigious
work and um we have enjoyed your books
and uh look forward to continuing our
conversation into the future
[Music]
you